das geschäft mit dem sex blut und es hat
dunkle seiten menschenhandel
zwangsprostitution
selbst wenn ich sterbe wer sucht mich
denn ich habe niemand
europa sucht nach dem richtigen weg soll
prostitution verboten werden das ist ein
hoch gewalttätiger hochkriminelle extrem
profitabler markt und das gehen dann
frauen gehandelt wie wenig fleisch doch
viele sind abhängig von dem gewerbe soll
ich machen wenn ich nicht komme kann ich
nichts essen solch verhindern während
die römer verbot diskutiert fühlen sich
wieder im stich gelassen die polizei
hilft uns nicht mehr wir sind auf uns
allein gestellt
was sagen sexarbeiter innen selbst dazu
und was würde ein verbot von sex kauf
eigentlich bringen wir reisen nach
österreich wo prostitution und bordelle
wie bei uns noch legal sind und nach
frankreich wo seit 2000 16.6 kauf
verboten ist
[Musik]
österreich wie ich bin verabredet an
einem für mich echt bizarren ort dem
angesagtesten sm bordell der stadt in
wien sind mehr als 300 modelle
registriert hauptsächlich kleinbetriebe
wie hier dieses hier ist er ein
luxusetablissement roland ist der
betreiber vermietet die zimmer an
selbstständige sex dienstleister inne
also ich für alles nach gummihandschuhe
kondome prüfen wolle so dass diese
männer wieder laufen können in den 70ern
wurde sexarbeit in österreich
entkriminalisiert genau wie in
deutschland ist zuhälterei heute
verboten bordell aber erlaubt hier
selbstständig arbeiten kann wer
volljährig ist sich bei der polizei
meldet unregelmäßig untersuchen lässt
aber genau wie in deutschland fordern
auch in österreich verschiedene
initiativen den kauf von sex zu
verbieten im milieu hält man das für
keine gute idee ich sage es wird im
prinzip weiter laufen hat hinter
verschlossenen türen ohne untersuchungen
ohne sicherheit ohne kontrolle ich
glaube dass man eigentlich ganz so gutes
system haben mir
auch sie kann sich ein verbot nicht
vorstellen wer nennen sie julia sie ist
domina und hat sich bewusst für diesen
job entschieden mit 20 hat sie
angefangen pornos zu drehen und sich
etwas dazu zu verdienen heute ist sie
lieber hier als am pornos seien
beim professionellen dreh bekommst du
500 euro grundsätzlich dass es noch
teilweise 45 stunden arbeit und hier
mache ich drei termine und also drei
termine oder drei stunden arbeit und ich
habe das gleiche und ich habe aber nicht
zwei stunden sechs haben müssen also
jetzt schon definitiv vielleicht für es
geht julia bietet keinen klassischen sex
an sie dominiert männer für geld ab 250
euro pro session
und da wird zugemacht
julias tag beginnt erstmal mit putzen
heute helfe ich hier dabei das studio
wird regelmäßig kontrolliert es
herrschen strenge auflagen nicht erst
seit
julia warnt davor sexarbeit zu verbieten
sie und ihre kolleginnen profitieren von
legalen strukturen das habe auch die
pandemie noch einmal gezeigt
und während des lockouts
stelle ich mir vor dabei arbeitsverbot
da ist wahrscheinlich dann auch
finanziell ganz schön viel weggebrochen
also wir haben schon vom staat bekommen
aber halt natürlich auch nicht jeder so
zum beispiel die leute diese illegal
machen haben sich hier kein geld
bekommen ich habe alles offiziell
angemeldet somit habe ich ein bisschen
geld bekommt ok also konntest du
im nebenzimmer dem sogenannten
klinikbereich ist julias kollege an die
gerade mit einem kunden fertig geworden
er ist dominus und quält andere männer
für geld ganz offiziell diese art von
sexarbeit ist hier erlaubt wird aber
streng kontrolliert alle sechs wochen
müssen sich sechs arbeitende auf
geschlechtskrankheiten testen lassen
alle drei monate auf hiv und syphilis
das ist ein programm sicherheit für den
arbeiten und auch für die kunden dass
keine sexuell übertragbaren krankheiten
deutschland und was ja befürchten würde
bronx kann rechtliche normen gibt es
illegal wäre natürlich die übergriffe
von kunden viel größer sein könnten
jemand da ist ja ein bisschen hier oder
auf sich aufpasst wenn du irgendwas sein
sollte entweder haben wir die
alarmknöpfe also ist wenn es darauf dass
fünf minuten später vielleicht zehn
minuten später die polizei wenn ich da
jetzt drauf drücken würde wird die
polizei kann
laut österreichischer behörden hat man
dank der staatlichen kontrolle noch ein
braten ins milieu war es im zweifel auch
dabei helfe missbrauchsfälle und
sexuelle gewalt aufzudecken für julia
steht der erste termin sie begrüßt die
staatliche kontrolle damit die die sich
bewusst für dieses metier entscheiden
sich erarbeiten können
kommen ihre speziellen fittiche ausleben
es gibt niemanden schlecht in dieser
hinsicht und somit so sollte es ja auch
eigentlich sein sexarbeit kann also von
legalen strukturen profitieren zumindest
habe ich hier zwischen lack leder und
premium preisen den eindruck gewonnen
aber klar ist auch dieses studio
speziell hinter den türen klassischer
laufhäuser werden die arbeitsbedingungen
wohl oft anders aus
um die 6000 sechs arbeiter innen sind
offiziell in österreich registriert mehr
als 90 prozent von ihnen stammen aus dem
ausland wie viele in illegalen
strukturen arbeiten kann niemand mit
sicherheit sagen
anti prostitutions aktivistinnen die
brigitte hofmann waren auch inter
legalen fassaden verstecke sich oft
zwang und menschenhandel sie fordert
eine gesellschaft ohne prostitution
setzt sich mit einer initiative dafür
ein sex kaufen österreich per gesetz zu
verbieten nach dem beispiel von schweden
das heißt natürlich nicht dass es keine
beziehung gibt also es gibt die alle
dinge die kläger als irgendwie trotzdem
aber dennoch gibt es mit einem gesetz
ein gesellschaftliches bekenntnis in
welche richtung wollen wir denn gehen
in skandinavien etabliert führten
zuletzt auch irland und frankreich das
sogenannte nordische modell ein es
stellt den kauf von sex für die freier
unter strafe sexarbeiterinnen sollen
ausstiegsmöglichkeiten angeboten werden
denn so kontrollierte bedingungen wie
ich sie msm studie lebt habe seien wohl
die ausnahme
also wir reden nicht über ich hab ein
studio und dann einen termin aus und so
über das reden wir nicht also das sind
frauen die sich selber gut organisieren
können aber der großteil der frauen ist
in einer situation wo das niemand
kümmert es geht hier eindeutig auch um
menschenhandel
das ist ein hoch gewalttätiger
hochkriminelle extrem profitablen markt
und auf dem dann frauen gehandelt wie
billigfleisch es geht darum das
abzustellen und die eu empfiehlt das
auch man kann das nur indem man die
nachfrage thematisieren das heißt es
geht um die männer es geht um die sex
käufer
wie kammern prostitution sicher machen
auch das eu-parlament hat sich schon
damit beschäftigt und 2014 sogar in
einer resolution das nordische modell
empfohlen also sechs kauf zu verbieten
aber was bedeutet das in der praxis ich
reise nach frankreich
paris stadt der liebe
rund um das berüchtigte moulin rouge
häufen sich tabledance leben peepshows
sexshops aber bordelle fehlanzeige in
frankreich ist sex kauf illegal
[Musik]
doch bis heute bleibt das gesetz
umstritten ein einflussreicher akteur in
diesem streit die ngo mit moni mit
schockierenden kampagnen macht sie auf
menschenhandel aufmerksam und ist ein
wichtiger verfechter des gesetzes
auf ihrer website gibt es zeugen
berichten von aussteigerinnen ich rufe
an und er halte einen kontakt eine junge
frau wie bereit ist mit mir zu sprechen
sie will nicht erkannt werden für diesen
film nimmt sie magali und unser treffen
beginn ganz anders als erwartet wir
machen witze lachen es ist unbeschwert
wenn sie ein gutes besonders mit dem
filter
doch das ändert sich schlagartig als
magali beginnt ihre geschichte zu
erzählen
aufgewachsen ohne eltern in kongos
hauptstadt kinshasa damit sie auf der
straße beginnt sich zu prostituieren mit
14 sie kauft gerade kondome als sie eine
verhängnisvolle begegnung macht eine
gruppe von weißen ist in den kongo
gekommen sie haben uns angeboten uns
nach europa zu bringen wir waren ja noch
kinder wir wussten nichts und wir hatten
niemanden um uns zu schützen
die männer versprechen ein besseres
leben in europa doch einmal angekommen
werden magali und ihre freundin
eingesperrt und zur prostitution
gezwungen ohne grenzen ohne lohn wir
wurden in große schicke häuser gebracht
pro tag waren es manchmal wir manchmal
sechs an wochenenden auch zehn freier
wir haben kein geld dafür bekommen
damit wir fit bleiben und nicht schlapp
machen und es gab zwei preise mit und
ohne konto
es dauert nicht lange da wird mal ich
schwanger von einem freier ins
krankenhaus kann sie nicht denn sie hat
keine papiere als die abtreibung
missglückt lassen die menschenhändler
sie gehen magali bringt das kind zur
welt mit 17 und der albtraum beginnt von
neuem
ich habe mit der kleinen pensionen
übernachtet und mich wieder prostituiert
ich war so fertig du gibst die kleine
jemandem zeit dafür zehn euro gest
anschaffen ohne zuhälter habe ich nicht
viel verdient 10 20 euro
magath ließ bald so verzweifelt dass sie
darüber nachdenkt sich von ihrer tochter
zu trennen sie kann das geld für
kindernahrung nicht mehr aufbringen dann
trifft sie eine mitarbeiterin der ngo
foundry sie fragte was ich mir vorstelle
ich sagte 'ich will aufhören ich schaff
das nicht mehr mit der kleine
es ist 2016 die französische regierung
verabschiedet gerade das
prostitutionsverbot und mit dem
ausstiegs programme prostituierte
erhalten eine finanzielle unterstützung
und die möglichkeit auf aufenthaltstitel
wenn sie nachweisen können dass sie mit
der prostitution aufgehört haben für
magali ist es die rettung
dass ich heute noch leben verdanke ich
dem gesetz kann ich alles haben was ich
will wenn
nicht meinen körper verkaufen sondern
ein job mit gehalt
der anfang meines lebens
magali arbeitet heute in einer großküche
sorgt selbstständig für sich und ihre
tochter auch dank des neuen modells doch
seit der einführung 2016 haben nur
einige hundert sexarbeiter innen so den
ausstieg geschafft geschätzt arbeiten
weiterhin mehrere zehntausende der
prostitution ob es wirklich weniger
menschenhandel und zwangsprostitution
gibt darüber gibt es bis jetzt keine
belastbaren daten wie geht es denjenigen
die weiterhin anschaffen der borde
bologna ein wald vor den toren der stadt
und frankreichs wohl berüchtigter
straßenstrich versteckt im wald oder in
parkenden autos wird weiterhin
angeschafft heute ist der großteil derer
die hier immer noch arbeiten
transsexuell viele sind illegal nach
frankreich gekommen geflohen vor gewalt
und diskriminierung und nehmen die
gefahr im wald weiterhin kauf weil sie
keine alternative sehen
und ich sag's wie es ist wohl fühle ich
mich hier nicht
ich bin seit machen wir mal so
auch so montana ist trans und schafft
seit über 30 jahren raten aber seit der
einführung des verbots greifen immer
mehr freier auf diskretere angebote im
internet zurück wo die polizei nicht so
einfaches spiel hat bis zum montag ist
die lage auf der straße dadurch
unerträglich geworden
das sechs mal weniger früher haben wir
ja am abend 120 150 euro gemacht wenn du
hier jetzt 20 oder 30 euro vielleicht
mal 40
es ist katastrophal
dazu kommt dass die stadt nach der
einführung des verbots auch die
straßenbeleuchtung ausgeschaltet hat was
die arbeit hier gefährlich
ohne laternen sind wir gezwungen uns
direkt auf die straße zu stellen ins
licht der autoscheinwerfer
wenn ich nämlich nicht so hinstellen
sehen mich die leute das ist gefährlich
wenn dann jemand aus weißt du dein typ
dass england romreise kann er dich
überfahren das ist schon passiert und es
gibt typen sie das mit absicht macht sie
rankommen auto und dann mitten im
interview ein kunde
ich komme gleich wieder
haben die g
20 euro der blow job sondern wir los so
heißt das geld ja
dann hatte ich geb dir das mikrofon ich
komme gleich wieder
können wir warten
das wissen müssen
das war wohl nichts log dich in den wald
völlig umsonst er wollte mich betatschen
aber nicht wenn du kein geld hast denn
ich mache das hier fürs geld nichts
anderes aber du siehst wenn so ein typ
dich im wald festhält was dann
dass die lage in bordeaux bologna immer
problematischer wird zeigt sich auch bei
tag zahlreiche in joe's engagieren sich
hier und sie schlagen alarm
zum beispiel die gruppe sos die einmal
die woche mit einem bus hierher kommt um
sich um die gesundheit der sexarbeiterin
zu kümmern patientinnen werden hier
kostenlos behandelt zum beispiel von
ärzten leoni wäre bereit
für eine vorsorgeuntersuchung
joana ist eine der ersten patientinnen
heute sie kommt aus ecuador und kennt
das prozedere schon
ich schlage vor dass wir auf alle
sexuell übertragbaren krankheiten testen
wir kommen dann nächste woche mit den
ergebnissen wider sollte es etwas zu
behandeln geben machen wir das dann
alles zusammen nächste woche okay
viele der sexarbeiter innen hier haben
keine papiere keine krankenversicherung
keine staatliche unterstützung
nur hier vor ort können wir diesen
menschen helfen sie sind oft vollkommen
verloren wissen nicht an wen sie sich
wenden sollen wann man
vorsorgeuntersuchungen braucht kennen
oft nicht einmal die krankheiten denen
sie hier ausgesetzt seien
die ärztin ist von der entwicklung seit
der einführung des ska verbots
schockiert fordern eine legalisierung
denn angesichts der prekären lage sein
viele sexarbeiter innen gezwungen auch
praktiken anzubieten die ein
gesundheitliches risiko darstellen zb
sex ohne kondom sie sieht den start
möglich
es ist das älteste gewerbe der welt das
bringt doch nichts einfach die augen zu
verschließen und so zu tun als gäbe es
das nicht heute ist es schlimmer als
jemals zuvor es ist zum schreien wenn
wir abends nach hause kommen wenn man
oft einfach nur los
[Musik]
aktuell unterstützt der staat
prostituierte in ausstiegsprogramm mit
330 euro pro monat für viele keine echte
alternative
denn oft hängt von dem verdienst auf dem
strich fiel ab auch für joana die vor
über 20 jahren für eine geschlechts
angleichung nach europa gekommen ist
ja hause hätte ich das hier nie gemacht
niemals aber ich komme aus einer sehr
armen familie wir haben gar kein geld
und ich kümmere mich um meine eltern
edition alt sind manche sagen würden
dass hierfür zuhälter machen aber ich
mache das von anfang an nur für meine
familie
johanna ist kein einzelfall um
ausstiegsprogramm in anspruch nehmen zu
können müssten die sexarbeiter innen
beweisen dass sie von heute auf morgen
mit dem anschaffen aufhören für viele
ist das unmöglich
ich habe bis jetzt 2020 und 21 versucht
mit einem anderen job aber ich musste
nach feierabend immer wieder dass hier
machen weil ich einfach nicht so viel
verdient habt dass ich wirklich hätte
aussteigen können
johanna sucht hilfe bei der gesundheits
in doha katar
die bahn seit jahren vor den gefahren
für sexarbeiter innen die trotz verbot
weiter anschaffen immer mehr freier
fordern beispielsweise sex ohne kondom
quasi als risikozuschlag im pariser büro
bietet die ngo unterstützung von
kostenlosen konto bis zur hilfe bei
behördengängen
mit der einführung des nordischen
modells in frankreich beginnt für
johanna der kampf um ihre existenz
sie verdient immer weniger geld auf dem
strich verliert ihre wohnung
gleichzeitig bekommt sie plötzlich immer
wieder ärger mit der polizei aufgrund
ihres jobs
mir geht es so schlecht
ich kann nachts nicht mehr schlafen
ich lege einfach da und mir rasen die
gedanken durch den kopf
ich habe keine wohnung mehr alles hat
sich vollkommen verändert seit dem neuen
gesetz
laut nicolas der leiter der ngo
scheitere das nordische modell in
frankreich in der praxis denn es zwingen
die sexarbeiter innen in die armut seine
organisation hat klage beim eugh gh
eingereicht
wir hoffen einfach dass der europäische
gerichtshof für menschenrechte im sinne
der sexarbeiter innen entscheidet es
geht darum sie zu schützen und es ihnen
zu erlauben unter den bestmöglichen
bedingungen zu arbeiten und natürlich
wenn sie es wünschen ausstieg programme
in anspruch zu liedern aber dafür
braucht es auch die finanziellen mittel
die es den personen erlaubt sich
weiterbilden zu können eine arbeit zu
finden französisch zu lernen ein dach
über dem kopf zu haben all die dinge die
man eben braucht um einen neuen
berufsweg zu beschreiten
sechs jahre nach einführung des 6 k
verbots hat die französische regierung
fehler eingeräumt es gebe viel zu
verbessern aber auch der liberale umgang
mit sexarbeit wie in deutschland und
österreich ist keine echte alternative
solange es menschenhandel und
zwangsprostitution wird und so sucht
europa weiter nach dem richtigen umgang
mit dem ältesten gewerbe der welt ich
habe für diesen film ganz
unterschiedliche sexarbeiter innen
kennengelernt 1 vereint sie alle sie
haben keine lobby oft keine stimme in
politik und gesellschaft
dabei sind sie es den wie bei dem thema
zu hören sollten